I don't know that means I need to
impress impress this French people come
on guys watch me - impressive - the gone
I'll try it I'll try it I'll try it I
don't know what I guess that house -
anguish best oh that's German hello and
welcome to PlayStation grenade it's been
such a good year 2019 has been awesome
but it's in the record books now so I've
been looking over some of the videos I
made this year and I've put together a
little best of series this one is all
about all the shenanigans we've got up
to in fortnight so let's relive some of
the old maps some of the old game modes
and some of the really brilliant things
that this game offered in 2019 today is
my birthday
and it's also the day we hit 500,000
subscribers so instead of a typical
video I just thought we play some games
and just have fun for fun sake I am The
King of pickaxe battles who wants to
take me on oh come on it's Harry Lee
yeah I do not lose pickaxe battles try
me but it was at this moment the atom
knew well let's get involved
here we go Joe quick where's your friend
John John week ended we need to make a
t-shirt on that wears nothing on reviews
when you need a break right in the balls
surely that was not the master plan
who'da thought you did someone in the
ball sack would make me so happy in a
world divided by chaos facing Cataclysm
only one man can save the universe
coming this summer the first revenger
his name is Adam arrow
[Applause]
honestly I feel like I've got the cheese
testicles in a history of mankind
all three weapon types oh it comes back
it's like a boomerang actually legit
feel really sorry for you there dude
it'll be sat there thinking check out my
bills I have got this sorted then
suddenly right up the rectum it's gotta
hurt why are we still here
just suffer 27:11 there 26 left after
this tiny snowballs box oh my word
let's legit the great thing I've ever
done Zack it went right on though it was
so good it was such I'll show you a
couple so as he starts building is one
by one there's a tiny gap at the bottom
to see speech the shot is off
it's a letterbox can he get him before
the floor is made it's in and it hits
him just before the floor is made I am
never gonna do something that good ever
again in my life
I love you off em assist
loud
and the first thing we must do we've got
to do some bunny hop in
well bang out some of the dances in a
minute let's see if we can get some more
of these chitara chitara Chicano
shooters enter shikari these things come
down to him boys
dance to your daddy the whole they all
left me no we have to do now we made up
meme it up nobody cares and that off
hold up hold up okay so I'm editing this
now and I've just noticed that that line
could be edited together with other
lines in this video to make this
[Music]
hospitality mom's sphaghetti you don't
know the amount of hours I've wasted
making that little bit we got a weapon
[Laughter]
will you play that dude there is
literally a weapon just in here go and
take it take it I try to be nice in
there is a weapon go on take the damn
weapon man
don't hide this I will get your weaponry
there here is this knife
why can you not help a brother out
sometimes this is why we can't have nice
things Barry you ask everyone meets up
and is given one minute to hide anywhere
on the island once that one minute is
over I can come and crush their dreams
but here's the best part
the hiders can only move when the storm
moves so as soon as that time it turns
blue
they must freeze in whatever position or
hiding-place they are in praying they
are not found by their the seeker it's
simple enough isn't it so let's do this
hide and Brees so you have one minutes
before I come and find you and kill you
off you go
[Music]
once you're hiding you can only move
when the storm moves okay what's going
on what are you doing ma'am
are you doing no thanks I'm not this not
this week
[Music]
[Music]
alright I'm coming for you now good luck
everyone
I'll be using the the replay theater
afterwards because I'm sure I'll run
past so many people and you can be just
like laughing there what we're gonna do
I'm do thank you so much for playing you
are the first real kill me yes how are
you doing brother thank you very much
for coming I really appreciate it good
chance the reaper billion won freely it
are perfect timing
thank you very much Jen know Lee and
SOOC thank you very much excellent hide
in gents hey guys thank you for playing
with you thank you give me an emote
please Oh
heartbreaking thank you very much good
to see you GG ah clever you know what
whoa you let you live here you live
sorry you can go you live you survived
the shop go oh thank you very much for
playing Arkham Knights good to see you
if you weren't together that first
person I wouldn't have found you what
what what what
well done you gave it away you need is a
suppressed weapons keep moving try to
move behind people get them killed
before you using the launch pad
don't build don't miss it
ripping shots now always survive it
oh she's five did it was your loss
who's left to left we have a winner we
have a winner
[Music]
well done come and come over here please
if you would
you may bludgeon me to death if you can
I feel like Ethan hunts illegitimate
brother Mike three in a row like I've
never hit three scopes nights in a row
ever trash we do behind there we have
one bullet day we don't take it until
the very last second come on come on
over we shot two faces all right for me
that was seven bullets six kills but
it's like looking my best ever ever ever
always the new silenced one let's test
out this baby what what that was I'm not
gonna shoot what we're going back we are
going back because I promise that was on
target and the bloom took it about six
feet to the right mom's sphaghetti lets
us run back that is gallivant lets us
re-engage with the enemy and hopefully
Surprise them like this
surprise mother this is my lazy links
thank you all for coming
[Music]
back it up back it in let me begin I
came the wit battle me it's good
how many can you have I've never seen
someone with somebody funky funky lunge
one oh I was gonna say if you land one I
will give you a free hit
it's all yours I will not shoot until
you shoot sir oh my word for a legit
second there I look like I knew how to
fortnight which is the best assassin
skin the new breathtaking Keanu or the
og Reaper which is the best John wick
today we will decide so sit back relax
use code Adam are you in the fortnight
shop and let's go to war we had a battle
inside the Continental with only John
wick and Reaper skins to decide once and
for all which is the greatest skin and
here's what happened when you hear the
airhorn you can pick axe the crap out of
everyone until only one survives don't
do it until the airhorn let the carnage
[Music]
[Music]
the last man standing was none other
than Marvel fanboy rockin the new John
wick skin so that scientifically proves
John wick is better than the reaper if
you disagree come fight me in the
comments bro
what would thumb us do in his day out
definitely till it's ours for this stop
the porn shop a word you can't open
doors with Thanos god dammit man
oops sorry okay sorry send me a bill
next and also posts for his favorite
taco right don't punch it shoot it now
don't shoot the kitchen bloody bloody
blood get out of them stupid way a few
inches later
you can't hide in your little huts
little piggy come on all of you at once
hey 1920 gals
boys bring on the cannon fodder
whoops okay opal jumped over Jeff I'm
still getting used to this map toys and
stuff I'll be there soon
26 more Avengers
27 avenges 28
you don't think I can pick it up
so I think this is my last month
whatever
32 Oh taking too many bullets now let's
go in soon fighting 34 oh that was so
good
to finish the stream we played a game of
John Wick's A's with 50 of the grenade
community and here's what happened John
wick says default dance John wick says
jump
some weekdays get away from the grenade
it was at this moment he knew he here we
go
I look he's behind there what would
Jesus do hello he'd probably use a
punting oh yeah yeah yeah here we go
ready for this thanks Jesus that's cuz
Jesus Christ is my friend he's got
friends we have this with a squeaky kid
come on squeaky foreign child this is
for you bro this is for you
oh that's too damn low looks like we're
playing defensive all right count down
with your traps in a low play this a one
full squad one solo and me you know here
comes
Oh gonna go three left now dudes what
are you gonna do
what's your battle plan
[Music]
Oh if noises don't you
oh yeah I can tell his name was what I
shouted at him okay well I've got
redeploy mate what have you got
you're not gonna raise your friends whoa
calm down right you've even got to hit
me out of the air or I am winning this
match nice nice
my dog died come on we know now that
I've won this I don't have to shoot we
won it for the noisy kids and
remembering what he said at the start of
the game he gave his advice he said to
us was the advice that got us through
that game GJ's then you do yeah G and
then C see wish you grew up in my era
ballsack this week in our Saturday
shenanigans I am playing with Zach you
but I forgot to record Zach's audio hope
so Zach will be replaced by an automated
voice and the good thing about this is
that I can make Zach say anything I want
isn't that right Zach use code Adam are
you in the fortnight shop I agree Gigi I
[Music]
learned what the word flaccid means
today the word flaccid gone and what
does it mean it means bored right are
you and you throwing me you do that on
purpose are you know what flaccid we no
I'm not I'm going flat it means bored I
know it does I call Bozek Siri what does
Fassett mean if part of the body
soft and hanging loosely oh I've been
saying facet all day we see soccer skins
here I feel like I'm murdering it or
something
thank you brother
dusty evil sting I can imagine
thanks forgetting that for me I'll give
you a golden weapons I'm a nice guy yeah
I don't get take something for nothing
I'm sorry about dude this is why I took
it I will show you now see him yeah I
know chi-chi's new bird have no name I'm
just the default never had a name it
would be did not expect a hit that you
and I really did with a John Cena
reference why am I such an idiot
are you sure about them hello and
welcome to PlayStation grenade is time
for some more shenanigans my favourite
game mode has been reintroduced into
power what there hello I am join sit
Oh joined the squad lobby I'm sorry how
did you get your oh listen to an
Englishman talking to a friend
Oh
what what yeah pickaxe how did you get
your listen oh man I love public loving
another there he is
where you going mate got a map
[Music]
you shall not pass oh this fight
I like third parties we left third party
we like we like to third party are you
hiding behind the tree Jesus Christ
that's Jason Bourne stealth.stealth is
my middle name
awesome boys let me take that again
there we go two left dreadful any shots
easy shots we will hit hard shots
there we go that's back to normal I feel
good again last guy I were I in last guy
I don't think you've got a clue he's
just having a nice day out please check
that back
I am certain that that was a nutmeg it
went straight through his legs tickle
his bow the way through
aha fast shooting works I still hate
bushes so we're gonna try and knock him
out with his own nails with your own
Nate we like to party we like we like to
party we like to party oh well you don't
see that every day
oh we've missed an opportunity we could
have done this like ali-a and something
I would have got mental at that can we
go back in time please I want to have a
go at doing this as ali-a oh my god oh
my god I'm gonna die I'm gonna die speak
be a miracle here we go here we go here
we go
can he see me ah perfect hiding place
behind a teddy bear what I would do for
that shotgun now let's do this here we
go one
that was the Wukong from earlier the one
that's knifed by the bloody gas station
damage is res damn I want your friend oh
right
let's see if that guy can get in this
circle come on dude
you got this we need some sort of flu
bad bad flute playing over this like
them see the Titanic one I don't want to
hit you I want to hit your builds you've
gotta be the circle come on do this
[Music]
[Applause]
you're so close you are so close faith
in you you got this bro come on good Oh
what you almost made it that was
anticlimactic my heart will go on um do
I just die no because I've completely
forgot what game mode were playing so me
and 20 spectators just sitting around
waiting to die
what can I say except you're dead I
don't play the game mode you shall see
[Laughter]
it's so good hey it's a PlayStation
default which is looking out the veranda
Oh No
[Music]
no no I don't do 90s I'm never gonna do
it 90 in my life I'll wait over here and
you'll do what everybody does is good at
building come out of your comfort zone
and get giving me a free headshot come
on Annie it's that rain down these
predictions hey you got to the end
thanks very much for watching if you did
get all the way to the end write in the
comments ali-a is better than ninja and
I shall try and reply to you also we
always finish with a dance now
celebrating those people who are kind
enough to use my code and amaru in the
fort night shop these guys have used it
over the last two weeks thank you very
much I salute you you're all against to
me if you'd like your name to be on
screen in one of these videos please get
in touch on Twitter my name is Adam
grenade over there and send a picture of
something you bought in the shop using
my code anyway it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for your time I'll
see you again next time